these are replicas of some of the
jewelry belonging to imelda marcos
part of a stash she tried to smuggle out
of the philippines after her husband
president ferdinand marcos was ousted in
a people's uprising in 1986
the artist pio abbad was partly inspired
by his parents who were anti-marcos
activists
the marcos vast collection of valuable
paintings are also on display reproduced
on postcards
visitors are encouraged to take some
home a way to reclaim what the artist
says belongs to filipinos
it
helps us to
remember
what the martial law period was about
and how the marcuses
used art and culture
how they acquired an ostentatious
collection of objects
that supported their idea of what
their life should be
the manila film center is seen as
another testament to marcos access
just two months before its grand opening
in 1982 there was an accident at the
construction site
emergency workers were barred from
entering the area for nine hours and the
then marcos administration ordered
immediate blackout
it's estimated at least 160 workers were
killed buried in concrete
this is an example of how the marcos
family do not care for people's lives
especially the workers one of the most
sorrowful things is they did that even
spare time to retrieve the bodies they
just ordered construction to continue
despite the tainted legacy ferdinand
marcos jr is the front runner to follow
in his father's footsteps
the kind of politics that we have it's
not much of a system to begin with it's
just you know a choice between different
political families and personalities
so while marcus may be an elite himself
he is not seen to belong to the same
group of elites that has ruled the
philippines in the past 30 years
other analysts say junior's rise can
mostly be attributed to a disinformation
campaign which aims to recast the rule
of marcos senior as a golden age for
filipinos if marcos junior succeeds it
would give him wide powers over
government agencies tasked to recover as
much as 10 billion dollars stolen by his
father during his 20-year rule florence
louis al jazeera manila